ah hi there Steve coffin here today I
want to talk a little bit about
listening reading which comes first
which is more important these are
subjects that come up all the time and
some people say I can't listen and so on
and so on or I can't listen to stuff
that I don't understand okay to my mind
the most important sort of activity in
language learning is listening and good
listening comprehension is the core
skill all right
listening has the advantage of being
something that we can do wherever
whenever it's relatively inexpensive and
so forth
but you can't listen to something that
you don't understand so the reading that
I do and especially now and again we
need to look at this in terms of the
stage you're at in the language so in
the case of Arabic and farsi I'm still
at a very early stage so I have to
listen many many times to the same two
three four minute story every time I
listen I gain something new a new
structure that I notice a new word that
I noticed that eventually I can convert
into something that I can use but when I
first listened to it of course I don't
understand them so the reading and the
saving of words and the reviewing of
words is really to prepare me for my
listening it enables the listening
sometimes before I did it this morning
for example before attacking a new
lesson I might listen to it in order to
get some momentum going into the 'really
it's especially a problem in Farsi
because we don't have text-to-speech so
in fact I was down there doing my
2-minute plank while listening to this
two-minute lesson then I save words and
read it and then I listen again and I'll
probably end up listening to that
particular lesson and and I see this
because I download my
my audio to my playlist where it tracks
how many times I listen and and the
listening in fact there was a video I
saw which which sort of says you know
from an evolutionary point of view we
were learnt we learn languages by
listening because reading or writing has
only been around for however many years
depending where you lived in the world
five six thousand years three thousand
years or less most people have always
relied on listening to learn language
listening is the best way to learn but
we can use reading to help make the
listening more meaningful to help us
learn words but listening is the key and
so that but this is in the early stages
I think at a later stage when we are now
more comfortable reading then we can
read books and the more we read the more
we learn about the language and we make
guess about the meaning and and reading
is a powerful way to improve your your
language skills even in your own
language
however the especially in the beginning
the key I'm increasingly convinced that
the key learning activity is listening
and we need to listen a lot but we need
to do all the things necessary to make
that that listening activity meaningful
and that means reading and reviewing
occasionally referring to grammar so
that when you listen you start to notice
some of these structures some of these
phrases some of these points of grammar
that you might have looked up and then
subsequently forgot about so you know in
fact this refers back to my planet there
I've got into flanking because my wife
got a video of YouTube about planking
and and plant you do these planks too to
use sort of two minutes three minutes
you know in this plank position in order
to strengthen your core because your
core is important in all of the
activities you do in sports or in life
in general
any movement of your body it usually
engages the core so having a strong
chorus is important while I think the
core in language learning is listening
so that's my thought for the day and I
would be interested in your comments
Thanks
[Music]